[Music]
there are countless stories of duos who
met on the set and became off-screen
friends but in other cases the lines
between reality and fiction and between
two people became starkly different here
are the tv friends who couldn't stand
each other in real life the landmark
sitcom from the 1950s i love lucy
starred lucille ball and vivian vance as
best friends and co-conspirators lucy
and ethel respectively however the two
actors had a fair amount of animosity
between them even though they were
supposed to play besties on the show
this tension started the moment that
vance walked onto the set there was an
unspoken rule in old school television
that no one should compete with the
leading lady in terms of looks ethel's
character was supposed to be slightly
older with a more middle-aged vibe and
ball was devastated to see that vance
was young and attractive instead so much
so that she wanted the new girl fired
over time however vance really began to
embody her character and her acting
skill won ball over professionally just
as her friendship eventually won her
over in real life their rivalry ended up
turning into an actual bond but their
relationship was quite rocky at the
start
on the 1998 supernatural drama charmed
phoebe and paige were played by alyssa
milano and rose mcgowan unfortunately
the two had a toxic relationship as
mcgowan later revealed in a twitter feud
in 2020 she accused milano of creating a
hostile environment on set behavior that
mcgowan called appalling mcgowan even
went so far as to say that she cried
every time the show got renewed because
of how difficult her experience was with
her co-star on the show paige and phoebe
have their fair share of differences but
at the end of the day they save each
other's lives and have each other's
backs as true friends and sisters would
but on twitter the pair really laid into
each other what started as a dispute
about politics escalated into mcgowan
taking on milano for everything from
being a fraud and co-opting mcgowan's
cultural reset movement to her salary
uncharmed allegedly despite what mcgowan
saw as a high salary milano threw a fit
on set saying that she wasn't paid
enough to quote do this
and mcgowan's opposition to milano's
behavior is just one of a few tense
relationships that milano was involved
in on the show why does she always pick
on me first
in 1995 the fifth series in the star
trek franchise hit american tvs becoming
a success for seven seasons and a
landmark show in the realm of
gender-balanced casting and the
representation of strong female
characters two of those characters ended
up becoming extremely close on star trek
voyager seven of nine played by jerry
ryan and captain catherine janeway
portrayed by kate mulgrew seven of nine
arrived on the scene as a foil to
captain janeway much as spock was to
captain kirk in the original series from
the beginning their relationship was
meant to be a close one in which the two
characters played off each other as the
series progressed the two became
confidants and friends in real life
however the tensions that arose from the
arrival of newcomer ryan in season 4
incited a tumultuous relationship
between the two stars with the addition
of ryan the ratings went through the
roof painfully leaving mulgrew in the
dust according to executive producer
rick berman speaking with woman's world
he recalled someone from the press
literally pushing past mulgrew to get to
ryan it hurt and it resulted in an
antagonism that persisted through the
end of the show for one example seven's
notorious skin-tight costume was an
element that drew attention from janeway
in favor of the newcomer allegedly
mulgrew even tried to prohibit ryan from
going to the bathroom during work hours
saying it took her too long to get out
of the costume yikes
in the original star trek series william
shatner known as captain kirk apparently
had some significant beef with leonard
nimoy who played kirk's foil and first
officer spock the beef was allegedly
because nimoy got more fan letters
despite his intended status as a
secondary character to kirk the
enterprise captain was supposed to be
the obvious protagonist and fan favorite
but audiences developed a keen affinity
for the pointy-eared science officer
much of this claim comes from george
takei who played sulu and had an even
bigger beef with shatner who also says
this fan mail story is made up but even
if the conflict over fan letters wasn't
part of it nimoy and shatner started off
on tense terms they clashed often in the
beginning of their professional career
in part because nimoy was so singularly
focused on making the most of his moment
though shatner went on to describe nimoy
as perhaps his only true friend this
relationship ended shortly before nimoy
passed away the man who played spock
suddenly cut shatner out of his life
without explanation and he died before
he or shatner could make amends
things aren't always as golden as they
may seem and all of the characters on
golden girls weren't as chummy in real
life as they may have appeared on tv
this was particularly true of b arthur
and betty white who portrayed dorothy
and rose respectively it was a distaste
primarily on arthur's part that stemmed
from her views on white's work ethic
apparently she loved to chat with the
audience between scenes instead of
staying focused as well as her attitude
the actress who played the cynical
dorothy was a bit cynical of white's
persona in real life according to those
who've worked with her white is a
pleasant sunshiny soul and that made her
pretty popular arthur however was
convinced that her upbeat attitude was
all an act white recalled in an hln
interview sometimes if i was happy she'd
be furious i don't know what i don't
know what i ever did i don't know but
she was not that thrilled with me while
arthur apparently wouldn't give betty
the time of day white true to her
established image has mostly kind words
to say about her former co-star she
shared you didn't mess with b b was very
strong but you loved her even apparently
if she didn't love you
in anger management charlie sheen and
selma blair played great friends
occasionally with benefits charlie
goodson and dr kate wales but off-screen
it was quite a different story their
tense relationship ended with blair
getting fired from the show via text
message leading up to the unceremonious
ousting was quite a lot of anger it
started when blair voiced concerns to
series executives about sheen's work
ethic the notoriously volatile star was
quite unhappy to see these remarks
leaked to the press giving a decisive
ultimatum to the producers they had to
choose between him and blair of course
as an executive producer and star of the
show it was obvious that sheen wasn't
going to get cut you can't fire me blair
was supposed to have a pretty
significant role on the show too but
obviously nothing that could compete
with sheen's role or his anger not only
did he tell her via text that her days
on anger management were over he
sprinkled in a few tasteless four-letter
words to boot
grace and karen are close friends on
will and grace but the actors who
portray them deborah messing and megan
malali were apparently anything but
while the last few episodes were filming
in 2019 malali missed two episodes
reportedly due to onset tension malali
later opened up on her husband nick
offerman's podcast about the fact that
she was being bullied at work were the
two incidents connected well the
description of the situation aligns with
the alleged feud between herself and
messing it's one involving a situation
at work in which she stood up for
herself and made things quote a thousand
times worse she also noted that it was
an ongoing and current situation in
january 2020 and will and grace was her
only regular engagement at that time
malali also ditched a cast interview
with messing in 2020 ahead of the series
finale her leave of absence from the
show suspiciously coincided with her
unfollowing both messing and fellow will
and grace actor sean hayes on social
media the latter malali has always
publicly gotten along well with on
offerman's podcast she hinted at the
drama behind this choice and her minimal
interaction with the cast she revealed
i'm pretty much on my own she added that
the alleged bully had recruited many of
her former allies to their side leaving
malala without the support she once had
like the on-again off-again friends they
portrayed on glee nya rivera and leah
michelle had a bit of a rocky
relationship rivera played cheerio's
cheerleading captain and glee club
member santana lopez while michelle
appeared in the role of the ambitious
and talented glee club captain rachel
berry on the show rachel and santana
began as bitter rivals but over multiple
periods of tension and reconciliation
they developed a reputation for their on
and off friendship the two live together
in new york city and demonstrate genuine
care for one another things couldn't
have been further from the truth in real
life in 2014 a fight on the set resulted
in one of them getting thrown offset or
storming out according to varying
reports either way rivera's character
ended up being written out of the glee
finale later she revealed that their
relationship got so bad that they didn't
speak for the whole of season six their
personalities she said were quote not a
good mixture however after rivera's
tragic death michelle paid tribute to
her co-star by posting a photo of her to
instagram alongside a pic of her late
partner and fellow glee co-star corey
monteith
the names mulder and scully are
synonymous with the idea of an iconic
duo however by the time the x-files
finished airing jillian anderson and
david duchovny reportedly couldn't stand
the sight of each other while duchovny
initially had positive things to say
about his co-star the relationship
deteriorated over the course of a series
of public comments by the two actors at
one point duchovny admitted that not
only did he and anderson not socialize
regularly but sometimes the attitude on
set amounted to be pretty bad as he put
it i'd rather be anywhere else but here
and i'm going to make you suffer for it
that's a pretty dismal revelation and it
wasn't the only one after the show ended
duchovny confirmed to metro that the two
were sick of each other by the time the
series ended saying quote familiarity
breeds contempt the two actors had an
undeniable spark from the start but
sometimes a spark can turn into a
difficult to control fire anderson
described long periods of their intense
relationship in which the two refused to
speak to each other often when they were
speaking duchovny revealed the two would
just argue about nothing
detective kate beckett played by stannah
katic and mystery novelist richard
castle played by nathan fillion were
great friends and star-crossed lovers on
abc's castle however in real life the
conflict between them grew so tense that
eventually katic left the show it must
have been a nightmare to work so closely
together while harboring such animosity
particularly for stannic haddick
allegedly she would go into her dressing
room and cry when filming was done
because of nastiness from fillion for
multiple seasons leading up to caddock's
departure and the show's subsequent
cancellation the actors reportedly
despised each other they also didn't
speak to each other outside of filming
according to us weekly the actors
actually had to go to couples counseling
together at the behest of the show this
was despite the fact that they were the
furthest thing from a couple unlike
their characters apparently though it
wasn't enough to save katic's spot on
the series she was subjected to a harsh
exit without according to her any
insight into the thought process behind
her expulsion
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]